hey everyone i'm alan and welcome to my
channel where today i am very excited to
talk to you all about psychonauts 2. uh
i am playing it right now thank you to
microsoft for giving me a code for the
game um this is currently running on an
xbox series s though i have also played
it on an xbox series x and basically i
found a bunch of questions people had
about psychonauts 2 and thought that i
would chat to you guys about it um it's
going to be fully spoiler free i'm not
even going to talk about the different
levels and the new abilities because
my absolute favorite thing about this
game is how
incredibly creative it is um
like i am consistently so delighted by
new creative ideas and how quickly they
feed them to you
uh that i just kind of didn't want to
spoil anything there is a chance that
they'll be
you know a character might reference
something that's happening in the story
at this point in the game and this save
is um maybe a quarter maybe a third of
the way through so it's still pretty
early so we're not gonna have anything
massively spoiled for you but for
context right out of the gate uh this
right here is basically your new
uh camp and of course you play as raz
and you have a lot of the same abilities
that you would have had before as well
as some new uh wonderful ones still
using this levitate ball wherever i can
the most common question i got is the
one that we'll answer first which is
as someone whose knowledge of the series
is based on james's love of the game
which for anyone who doesn't know james
williams uh is a friend of mine who
absolutely loves psychonauts
um who i used to work with do you need
to play the first one to understand and
enjoy this one i tried to pick up the
first one recently and it just felt too
outdated for me to really get into it
but i would love to hop into this one
when it comes out
so
i would say
you do not need to play the first
psychonauts um it's a bummer that you
feel like it's two dated i would still
highly recommend the first psychonauts
to anyone who's not played it before i
think it's fantastic um but no you won't
need it in order to be able to enjoy
this game at all you'll be absolutely
fine uh there are a new cast of
characters who are
friendly and lovable and and
exciting to learn about however
psychonauts
would it be weird
um
pretty clearly a lot of references to
the first game um they do give you this
little like video thing at the very
beginning
that's my bad too early um
that will give you like kind of a recap
on stuff and there are a lot of like
cute little jokes to begin with that
reference the first psychonauts but
yeah you won't actually need to
have played it you'll be totally fine so
we also got
how would you rate james and elise's va
performance oh this is a personal
question which i will jump straight to
because i also got asked about this a
lot um so yes james and elise voice a
couple in the game you will find them
for anyone who knows me from funhouse
you'll know all about them they
announced uh that they're in the game
and it is really cute i texted uh the
both of them the minute that i found
them and you will find them and it's
actually quite early it's like one of
your second brain worlds and you can't
miss them there is no way you'll miss
them um and
it's very obvious that it's them and
it's it's very very cute it's a really
pleasant silly exchange and
i think you know that's kind of
reflective of
the game in general it's just
very
creative pleasant fun like i smile so
much when playing this game i'm having a
really good time um while i'm here
before we jump to the next question why
don't i just show you guys
this the level up system in the
automatic so you can get pins over here
um
that's what i currently have is a
sapphire levitate ball but you can also
go green or go red and i think you can
mix and match them as well these are all
different pins that are related to
levitation i won't share too much about
mental connection or clairvoyance um
melee bedazzle your enemies while
pummeling them with full spectrum fists
uh this one we can do this so that
whenever you stand around not doing
anything that will make rounds dance um
but otherwise we have items here
uh which i will say i've
i barely used at all these cycles are
pretty important that's how you level up
uh in part as well as collecting cards
but you'll find a lot of them so you
don't really need to buy them um and i
never bought
cypops or dreamfluffs uh at all um the
game is really easy it is really really
easy and i'm really bad at platforming
and there's plenty of platforming um you
will slowly have your health you know
taken down if you fall off platforms but
even then uh very rarely died it is
definitely a simple game so yeah that's
that's the automatic that is your basic
level up system right there and now if
we stand still raz will probably start
to dance andrew courtney said i just
want to know if the platform feels good
and are the controls easy to use yes and
yes
and it's a very cute game but yeah um
platforming feels great to me i love all
the levitation-based abilities i just i
think that you know i just kind of use
them intuitively even when i don't need
them when running around the world the
only thing that i dislike actually
control wise
this wheel that we've just brought up
here is how you equip your abilities and
on the xbox controller i think i'm
probably covering
two of them with the screen right now i
am if i move my webcam
so you only have four that you can map
at any one time i really wish they had
figured out a way to map more because i
had to open up this menu
pretty often you have to just hold up on
the d-pad
and then you'll go to something and you
can
uh equip it you know that's currently on
rb but say that i wanted to equip my
cyblast which for the record i would
recommend uh leveling up very early if
you can very helpful one to have
um that means i no longer have
pyrokinesis so you
you are limited to four um and it never
really feels like enough i have to swap
them out so often and figure out like
what do i need and they're all pretty
useful honestly so um that's one thing
that i don't love i wish there was like
a maybe you could hold two buttons to do
something or hold something in or
yeah i would prefer if i didn't have to
remap quite so often uh tuc said is
there a strong collect-a-thon aspect to
it do you frequently run into stuff that
plops away and you go i guess i should
collect all of these then
uh absolutely yes you are
uh still bombarded
with figments in this game uh much the
same as the first game which is a thing
that i
definitely have problems with i'll be
honest because i have trouble not
collecting them
um so that is definitely a thing you are
going to spend a significant amount of
time going and collecting figments that
you'll find
and yeah here you can already see there
are cards up there
and up there as well so uh
just this part alone we can see that
three things
uh for me to collect just in this one
kind of lobby area of the psychonauts
big super ass what is something about
the game that makes you want to play it
so badly and or recommend it to others
thank you and take care
look this game
is
just i think i mentioned this already
but just so creative mind-blowingly
creative i feel like
every level is so different i'm very
impressed by a lot of the new psychic
abilities and kind of how complicated
they are you know when when i was
thinking about what they were going to
put in this game it's like they
basically covered everything in the
original psychonauts what are the
abilities going to be but the new
abilities are really fun really creative
oh i've got to get that automatic
get more
cyonium a lot of puns um
and and really
constantly changes up the gameplay you
know one minute you're engaged in combat
and then you're
jumping through the air trying to fix
people's thought patterns and then your
skating and it's just
really
unexpected surprising all the way um
from the level design to
the literal level themes they do still
tackle a lot of
you know personal themes um and the
characters i just think it's it's so so
so creative and it's also just really
fun it's just a really pleasant video
game alien race said my favorite part of
the first game involved gaining insight
of the character's subconscious psyche
by exploring the levels inside their
minds the levels in the sequel still
have that depth where you feel like
you're learning intimate details about a
character as you go through their level
definitely yes um they are like palaces
in persona
um
oh i think uh generally
longer and a bit more detailed than they
were in the first game but absolutely
yes um it still deals with you know some
technically adult themes it does have a
warning at the start of the game telling
you about some of these themes but i
think that it handles them really well
um
a lot of the things that you know i
think other games would have difficulty
tackling because they are
you know challenging things that are
happening to people and you're going
inside their brains and assessing those
things but i feel like it does a really
really good job
of acknowledging
some
of acknowledging some serious topics but
also
of keeping things light-hearted you
don't feel like you're being lectured at
any point
uh but it's not like it shies away from
being mature i gotta get rid of this
dancing pin
i'm sorry razz you gotta stop doing it
i'm i'm trying to read questions here
scott n said what can you tell us about
the story is it one that'll keep players
engaged for the entirety of the game
i don't want to spoil the story um the
very very very brief
uh synopsis that you will learn very
quickly that has probably already been
shared is that there is a mole inside of
the psychonauts that's introduced
virtually immediately in the game and
you have to figure out who it is um and
it's a lot more complicated than that of
course as it actually plays out
uh but yes i do think the the story is
very engaging um more
for the creative cast of characters
again you'll get to know these two
pretty well um some of them are awesome
and i love them and some of them are
jerks but i love them too
but yeah i i definitely think there's
there's virtually no chance that people
you know won't stay engaged um
probably my number one least favorite
thing about the game and i know this is
in a lot of ways personal preference
um
but it's something that you know i've
other games have also done um jeremy
nuts and metal gear solid four
is this game has a lot of cutscenes and
breaks up gameplay
so frequently like say something could
be it feels like you walk for five
seconds and there's a cutscene and then
you walk for another 10 seconds and
there's a cutscene there are a lot
of cutscenes there's a lot of story not
in a way that ever feels tedious again
because i think the cast of characters
is so great and it is really funny
cheeky light-hearted so it's fun to
watch
but i've always found that frustrating
as a player
i think i just a game design thing that
i don't like um i certainly wish that
they would either let the dialogue
happen while the player is engaging in
an action
or they would just keep with one
cutscene don't give me control and then
take control away so rapidly and this
game really does do it a lot there are
tons of cutscenes and it throws them at
you all the time um and and takes
control away from the player yeah i find
it really jarring and i feel like it's i
just feel like you know it's a video
game let me do video game stuff while
telling the story like get more creative
rather than just showing me little
snippets of films uh but i know that a
lot of people don't care about that in
this i found psychonauts too to be
particularly egregious about it though i
did feel like it happened all the time
to the extent that i was like god just
couldn't isn't there some other way that
you could tell me this information
rather than having to stop me
all the time especially when
just doing this is so fun
you know what if you were to do a
half-life and convey the information
while i can run around on my little
levitate ball in a room
because when it's so fun to play
uh i think it's extra frustrating to
have control taken away and with the
xbox series upgrade how does it compare
to something like ratchet and clank
rift-a-pop
i mean clearly this game doesn't look as
good as ratchet and clank rift-a-pot but
i think that comes down to a different
art style
um
it looks like psychonauts it looks a
little bit more clay everything is uh
intentionally i think a little bit
duller it doesn't have that that
graphical fidelity that um ratchet and
plank rift apart does where you're
playing that game and you're like oh my
god this is so scenic and so beautiful
it is a lot more in the really specific
design really consistent art style uh
not that ratchet clank doesn't have that
as well but you know this this is what
the game looks like it's definitely a
little bit flatter but i was at no point
bothered by that i i really like the
consistency in the art style and uh as
for technical issues the only thing that
i've had is occasionally some popping
mostly happens in the cutscenes um but
yeah just seeing textures pop in
is something that's happened somewhat
frequently certainly more when i've been
playing on the series s than on the
series x though there are a fair amount
of loading screens but they are all very
short but otherwise i would say it's
it's wonderfully
polished david mcintyre said does the
humor and quirkyness hold up i'm worried
it'll come off as quaint after so much
time i really hope it holds up like it
is occasionally laugh out loud funny not
all the time um it's mostly like
cute kind of funny like very pleasant
uh sense of humor but yeah the humor
still holds up it it's really well
written it's cheeky um and it's not
you know
the next question directly after this
was would it be considered a children's
game or does it have more dark adult
humor um
it
i don't even know how we even really
quantify what a children's game is
anymore but yeah it has tons of dark
adult humor it's funny in a way that is
wholesome but not like too wholesome you
know it's not not every character is
nice not every character is smart some
of them are goofy and ugly and dorky and
it really does know what it is and what
its tone is and it really owns that and
i really uh appreciate that about it oh
by the way
he's right here
uh little um boss travel hubs they will
let you kind of swap between areas in
this this main central hub so that you
don't have to
levitate
your whole way there though you know why
would you want to do anything else
that's my question why would you not
want to roll on your sweet levitation
ball khalil said does it seem like it
has a lot of replay value
yeah some cool things about that when
you finish the game you can go back
through all of the levels and uh
actually when you finish the game they
will be a little bit different which is
cool there is a post game
so
not only are the levels uh definitely
replayable you're going to want to go
get all your figments you're going to
want to go get all your bag tags um
the million other
psychology related puns that are worked
into this game are all there but uh yeah
there is a
postgame
state
that adds a little bit more content and
some changes to the content that is
already there michael donahue uh said is
the audio good um
yes
the score is brilliant the music has me
legitimately smiling it is it is so
wonderful and and obviously diff is
depending on where you are and what
you're doing but uh
yeah the the music's fantastic i mean
the audio design in general i have
absolutely no complaints about it's it's
great
but uh i did definitely want to shout
out the music i actually don't know who
composed it but whoever did did a really
really good job it's jazzy it's funky
it's stylish
and again really consistent with the
tone of the game and i you know i think
they did a very very good job of just
capturing whatever this essence of
psychonauts is top to bottom
every part of the game it's really
really impressive that is not easy to do
especially when the first game came out
so long ago vast majority of the
questions are all is it good do you like
it is it fun uh yes i do think this game
is good um i have mentioned the couple
of things i don't love about it the the
uh very frequent cutscenes being the
main one and i'm not a huge fan of the
collect-a-thon
uh theme in general but otherwise uh i
do think the game is really wonderful i
think a lot of people are gonna have a
really good time with it
and um yeah i wanted to limit to like i
said showing you guys this area so that
i'm not spoiling any of the best parts
of the game which are everyone's mind
palaces um they're so varied and so much
smarter than i expected them to be but
that is pretty much it if anyone has any
more questions uh before you all get to
play the game tomorrow please do let me
know i'm happy to answer them but
otherwise that is it for me today
everyone i will see you guys next time